in 2015 Brazil began experiencing a
major public health crisis a large
number of babies are being born of
microcephaly a birth defect that results
in abnormally small head an
underdeveloped brain at the same time
researchers discovered that Zika virus
was spreading around the population Zika
virus is spread by mosquitoes and can
cause fever like symptoms researchers
began to wonder because Zika virus also
be responsible for the uptick in
microcephaly you may have heard the
phrase correlation does not equal
causation this is a problem that plagued
epidemiologists when they were trying to
figure out what the symptoms of Zika
actually work State and microcephaly
were occurring at the same time in the
same place meaning that they were
correlated but it is possible that
microcephaly was being caused by
something completely unrelated to Zika
in fact during the outbreak in Brazil
some people believed that chemicals not
a virus were causing the uptick in
microcephaly in order to properly
understand whether Zika was causing
microcephaly epidemiologists engaged a
variety of methods they had to rule out
other causes conduct case controls
comparing microcephaly within Zika
affected areas to non affected areas and
monitor Zika infected women during
pregnancy to determine if and when
microcephaly occurred during development
epidemiologists also tested the disease
on animal models and analyzed the
molecular mechanisms of the virus in
2016 the World Health Organization
confirmed that there was scientific
consensus that Zika causes microcephaly
in addition to understanding the
symptoms of a disease epidemiology
involves tracing the origin and route of
the disease to determine its evolution
how is it that microcephaly came to be a
symptom of Zika when it wasn't before
the Zika virus originated in the Zika
forest of Uganda where it started out as
a relatively mild disease its symptoms
were fever rash headache and achiness
researchers discovered that it was
spread via the 80s mosquito and that it
could infect both humans and monkeys
further research in Zika transmission in
humans showed that it could be sexually
transmitted as well from the 1951 to
2006 Zika was identified
14 separate times throughout Africa and
South Asia until 2007 however there were
no large-scale outbreaks at this point
there was an outbreak on the island of
Yap
the CDC conducted studies and collected
samples and eventually determined that
almost 75% of the population had Zika a
second epidemic occurred in 2013 in
French Polynesia at this point
epidemiologists noticed a new symptom
associated with Zika Guilin Barre
syndrome an autoimmune disease that can
cause temporary paralysis by 2014 zika
had arrived in brazil probably by plane
but microcephaly had never been a
symptom of Zika before and people
outside of South America who contracted
Zika were not experiencing the same
abnormally high rates of microcephaly
epidemiologists developed a hypothesis
that there are two main strains of Zika
virus an African lineage and an Asian
lineage at some point the asian lineage
split off from the African lineage and
acquired the ability to cause
microcephaly through a mutation to the
virus's genome therefore only
populations infected with the Asian
lineage of Zika would experience
microcephaly as a symptom of Zika while
those infected but the African lineage
would not microcephaly is a public
health crisis once epidemiologists
confirmed that microcephaly is a symptom
the Zika the epidemic was declared an
international emergency in 2015 leading
to the influx of funds to help fight the
disease the COS dica only causes
microcephaly in unborn infants it became
most important to protect pregnant
mothers from being infected with the
virus in 2015 Brazil urged the
population to avoid pregnancy in many
countries such as the United States
advised their citizens not to travel to
zika-affected countries while pregnant
because dicas spread by mosquitoes
mosquito eradication efforts were also
effective mechanisms of reducing the
number of infected individuals
additionally various vaccines have been
in development since the crisis first
broke out hopefully learning from the
Zika crisis will be more prepared for
not only the next Zika epidemic but also
any emerging disease